und ich begrüße jetzt professor stefan
kooths vom kieler
weltwirtschaftsinstitut herr codes der
sachverständigenrat der bundesregierung
zur begutachtung der
gesamtwirtschaftlichen entwicklung legt
heute um 11 seine aktualisierte
wirtschaftsprognose für 2020 und 20 21
vor
was erwarten sie da ich erwarte dass
sich an den zahlen für die
wirtschaftsleistung gar nicht so viel
verändern dürfte das aber das bild
dahinter also die zusammensetzung
deutlich neu vorgenommen wird und zwar
in der weise dass wir von der
exportwirtschaft und damit von der
industrie deutlich stärkere impulse
sehen werden während die konsumnahen
dienstleistungsbereich noch länger
zurück hängen werden das hat viel mit
den lockdown maßnahmen zu tun die jetzt
über das winterhalbjahr in kraft waren
und die in dem vorangegangenen gutachten
eben noch nicht berücksichtigt werden
konnten anfang des jahres haben sie ja
gesagt im frühjahr wird die konjunktur
wieder kräftig anziehen
bleiben sie immer noch dabei dass das
jetzt losgeht weil wir sind ja im
frühjahr oder wird es durch diesen
lockdown den wir gerade erleben sich
wieder alles nach hinten verschieben
ja das früher ist für konjunkturforscher
nicht so kalendarisch gemeint sondern
immer das zweite quartal und in der tat
gehen wir davon aus dass im laufe des
zweiten quartals die lockerungen dann
auch in größerem maße stattfinden können
und wenn das der fall ist dann werden
die vielen dienstleistern die jetzt noch
in den startlöchern festsetzen
dann durchstarten und wir haben im
dritten quartal des vergangenen jahres
gesehen wie kräftig dann so ein neustart
ausfallen kann
es spricht nichts dafür dass es diesmal
anders sein sollte
das heißt sobald die bremsen für die
binnenwirtschaft gelockert werden können
wird auch die ökonomische aktivität
kräftig zurück kommen und ich gehe davon
aus dass der sachverständigenrat das
heute genau so beurteilen wird sie haben
ja auch die prognose gewagt
wenn jetzt die konjunktur wieder anzieht
vor allen dingen der gastronomie in der
reiseindustrie aber auch bei den
konsumgütern dass man dann noch damit
rechnen muss dass die preise nach oben
schnellen werden wo ist da der
zusammenhang in der tat
es kann sein dass wir nicht nur die
aktivität sehr kräftig zurück kommen
sehen sondern auch so etwas wie ein
preisschub erleben werden
das hat damit vor allen dingen zu tun
dass die privaten haushalte während der
pandemie zeit nicht im gewohnten maße
ihre ausgaben tätigen konnten und wir
schätzen dass allein in den jahren 2020
und 20 21
etwa 230 milliarden euro an kaufkraft
bei den privaten haushalten liegen
geblieben ist also zusätzliche ersparnis
gebildet worden ist und ein teil davon
dürfte sich dann in zusätzlichen konsum
nachfrage entladen
das trifft dann aber auf kapazitäten in
der gastronomie im einzelhandel oder
auch bei vielen unterhaltungs
dienstleistern im tourismusbereich die
begrenzt ist und je dringlicher der
wunsch ist
bislang liegen gebliebenen konsum
nachzuholen desto eher werden die
menschen bereits sein eben auch etwas
tiefer in die tasche zu greifen
das macht mir aber jetzt ein bisschen
angst weil wenn man mal an die
ersparnisse denkt da könnte es ja
wirklich zu einer inflation in
deutschland und in europa kommen
wenn jetzt tatsächlich all das
nachträglich verausgabt würde was zuvor
gespart wurde
dann wäre das so aber davon gehen wir
derzeit nicht aus und es ist natürlich
ein temporärer effekt also wenn dann
dieser schwall sich entladen hat dann
war es das auch also das wäre dann eben
nicht der vorbote zu einem dauerhaft
höheren inflationstrend sie machen ja
jetzt ein ganz rosiges bild von der
zukunft aber eine
man müsste uns doch eigentlich sorgen
machen der staat hat ja im letzten jahr
und jetzt auch schon in diesem jahr
milliarden wenn nicht sogar millionen
ausgegeben um die wirtschaft am laufen
zu halten um zu stützen kurzarbeitergeld
wurde ausgezahlt corona hilfen viele
leistungen wo auch keine wirtschaftliche
gegenleistung dagegen steht wann kommt
denn da das bittere ende dass der staat
auf die bremse tritt und wir einspringen
müssen
ja also um nicht missverstanden zu
werden rosig ist das bild nicht
wir sehen eben ein aufholprozess nachdem
aber die wirtschaftsleistung dramatisch
zuvor eingebrochen war also wir kommen
allmählich zurück auf die
vorkrisenniveaus damit ist aber die
krise längst nicht ausgestanden wir
dürften durch die pandemie etwa eine
millionen jobs verloren haben im
vergleich zu einer situation ohne eine
solche krise und sie haben es
angesprochen der staat hat viel geld
ausgegeben und ab dem jahr 2022 ist dann
konsolidierung angesagt wir rechnen
damit dass die dass der gesamtstaat
einen zu hohes defizit haben wird von
etwa 40 milliarden euro die konsolidiert
werden müssen
über alle staatlichen ebenen hinweg das
heißt die nächste bundesregierung wird
dann keine bundesregierung sein die das
geld mit vollen händen ausgeben kann
sondern die dann die unangenehme aufgabe
hat die haushalte wieder ins
gleichgewicht zu bringen
das sagt stefan kooths professor am
kieler weltwirtschaftsinstitut
herzlichen dank für das gespräch
sehr gerne